l'île de la réunion un des endroits sur
terre où la nature fait encore la loi
loin des plages ensoleillées les volcans
ici ont érigé de prodigieuses muraille
c'est dans ce décor féerique que se joue
l'une des courses les plus difficiles au
monde
2500 athlètes venus du monde entier sont
réunis pour participer à l'exploit
traversé l'île en passant par les
sentiers les plus inaccessibles
le tout en moins de soixante dix heures
elle s'appelle le grand raid
mais ici tout le monde la surnomme la
diagonale des fous
la cour se fait de jour comme de nuit il
faudra allonger des falaises de
plusieurs centaines de mètres
évitez les crevasses qui parfois peuvent
être fatales les corses ont détruit au
fur et à mesure des étapes on est
écoeuré abritée par la fatigue on ne
maîtrise plus rien cette course est un
véritable enfer nous avons suivi ce
qu'ils font du grand raid 1 paraît hors
norme
voici l'histoire d'une course pas comme
les autres
simplement j'ai côtoyé non pas les
entrailles à gêner personne laisse
ligoter y installa vous reviendrez moi
je ne tiens monsieur et madame tu as
envie c'est d'y aller je reviens vous
pouvez madame on avait fini en soit on
voit là c'est bien mais ça continue le
rejet le dire mais c'est bien madame le
diable a fini à les ans cette dame ses
réussites letting dame cliqué tout temps
dans le coin et qui fait ses prédictions
on l'écouterait après ses bons messages
que vous reprenez pas qu'elle vienne me
dérangeait ton boulot c'est de tout
gérer
minute par minute effectivement mais
voilà il ya les imprévus que tout mais
bon ça se passe tout le temps ça se
passe toujours bien y'a pas de problème
de diplômes au maximum oui le maximum
les bénévoles du grand raid doivent le
réaliser sur une traversée
exceptionnelle de saint-philippe au
stade de la redoute 150 kilomètres à
parcourir sur un tracé au style comme
ici avec le piton de la fournaise le
volcan accueille la première étape il
faut en moyenne sept heures pour y
arriver dans un décor lunaire
ensuite c'est une végétation extrême
qu'il faudra traverser et se faire un
chemin en pleine nature sauvage
[Musique]
parfois ce sont des manches cascade qui
barrent la route des à plein
il faut alors faire de gigantesques
détour pour passer d'une rive à l'autre
et centaines de mètres qui vous épuise
lorsque l'on court depuis plus de trente
heures
d'autres fois ce sont des chemins à
flanc de montagne qu'il faut franchir
ceux qui ont peur du vide feront
demi-tour
il y à issy plus de 900 mètres de vide
cette course c'est 9000 mètres de
dénivelé l'équivalent de l'everest
le tout en moins de 24 heures pour les
plus forts soixante heures pour les
autres sans compter tous ceux qui
abandonnent en cours de route
le grand raid est une invention
incroyable que peu d'hommes pourront
tenter les préparatifs du grand raid ont
commencé plusieurs mois avant la course
des milliers de médicaments ont été
réparties sur l'ensemble du parcours
pour répondre aux premiers secours
il aura fallu l'intervention des
hélicoptères pour acheminer des dizaines
de palettes rempli des premiers soins
les pompiers de l'île ont été
réquisitionnés pour porter secours en
cas d'accident
la presse fait sa une depuis plusieurs
jours avec le grand raid
la vente des journaux explose
des milliers de repas sont préparés pour
les coureurs les magasins de sport sont
bondés le grand raid est dans toutes les
têtes
tout le monde s'entraîne l'île de la
réunion vit au rythme de cette course
effrénée
l'heure est aux derniers petits détails
pour le chef des bénévoles tout le monde
s'applique la ligne de départ des
coureurs doit être installé avant la
tombée de la nuit alors assez la
commission n'a fait là comme on l'a fait
part ici là il faut que ce soit assez
l'âge
combien m ah non pas de match ce qui a
plus à y regarder s'il ya au moins 4 m
vingt deux mille trois cents concurrents
qui sont dans le parc fermé
un parc qui accueillera une vingtaine de
nationalités
ces coureurs ont tous participé à des
épreuves sportives qualifiés d'extrêmes
certains ont déjà couru le grand raid
d'autres ont fait d iron man ces
fameuses courses réservées à l'élite du
sport où l'on doit nager courir et faire
du vélo sur des centaines de kilomètres
autant dire qu'ici il n'y a pas de place
pour les touristes direction sous la
banderole la ligne de départ
ceux qui sont là n'ont pas d'autre
objectif que de gagner cette course les
autres derrière attendre tranquillement
le coup d'envoi ils sont plus fataliste
pour eux arrivés à saint denis constitue
un exploit mais tous ont conscience que
c'est un enfer qu'ils vont affronter
pour aller jusqu'à la redoute et non que
148 km a fait ils vont vite arriver nous
arrivés là
[Musique]
eric domitien connaît bien la musique
tous les ans c'est lui qui a la
responsabilité du départ de la course
et participez au grand raid c'est ma vie
il a couru la diagonale des fous
plusieurs fois mais suite à des
problèmes de santé
eric a dû se reconvertir il poursuit sa
passion différemment aujourd'hui
et c'est être aussi rigoureux que lors
de ses nombreux entraînements de
l'époque partir de maintenant on va dire
à la machine et est vraiment lancée pour
vous y a pas d'amis il n'y a pas de
familles d'un côté comme de l'autre
c'est échanges interdit strictement
sagna dit donc pour tout le monde est
mon grand des danois
[Musique]
c'est tout et qui participe au grand
raid
même le petit cirque de la réunion a été
réquisitionné pour cette occasion
[Musique]
le vainqueur de l'appréciation en fait
ils étaient 2 est donc un jack euro
n'est ce pas qui va reprendre le départ
et qui sera là donc
mais il ya toute une horde de
prétendants il ya des garçons comme
normand qui a gagné quand même le
dernier trail du mont blanc et beaucoup
d'entrain savez vous avez des gens qui
perdent l'impatience et qui vont
certainement se révéler au cours cette
course
merci au revoir comédien
ceux-ci qui à radio free dom où il m'a
fait ensemble radio freedom
non c'est pas d'émotions c'est sous les
portes à ses sorts ce qu'on dit pas
tellement à qui on s'adresse
ah bon parce qu'on a pris du retard la
manière ça me gêne un petit peu salée
pris du retard
et puis ensuite à se bousculer et on
sait pas du tout quand le courant est
rétabli
je sais pas on est privé de courant
électrique
alors c'est pas trop gênant pour le
contrôle pas ce soit à peu près mais
pour le système de code-barres c'est
plus difficile
donc tant qu'on n'a pas le court on peut
lancer sur portable sauf aux tables
alors on fait quoi 1-2-3 comme ça ouais
l'ambiance est tendue à une heure du
départ seulement la panne d'électricité
plonge tout le monde en noir c'est un
problème pour les organisateurs et une
atmosphère particulière pour les
coureurs
ce manque de lumière rappelle
l'obscurité totale que vont affronter
des coureurs lorsque les lumières de la
ville disparaîtront
dans quelques heures ce sera bien pire
et ils le savent tous pour faire face à
l' angoisse
les athlètes se réunissent se rapproche
les derniers arrivés présentent leurs
sacs à dos remplis d'objets
indispensable à une telle course
toujours sous la faible lueur de
quelques lampes torches en attendant
patiemment le retour des projecteurs
[Musique]
et à 23 heures la lumière est enfin de
retour à vallet vit un peu dans la
chimie d'un coup ça va c'est pas aussi
clair que ça
allez moi savoir comme ça sur mon père
me retrouve le coup d'envoi son approche
la fête bat son plein les danseuses de
la réunion s'en donnent à coeur joie
ceux qui en profitent sont les plus
détendus ils ont généralement plusieurs
grands raids alors active où ce sont des
vedettes aguerris des compétitions comme
l'ancien champion de cyclisme laurent
jalabert dernier geste pour rentrer
totalement dans la course dernières
interviews aux médias de métropole on
sent le souffle chaud de la course se
faire de plus en présent on va ouvrir
laisser passer la horde de compositeurs
tels sont il faut attendre ici faut
attendre là bas aussi peut-être de côté
enfin savoir c'est cool tranquille
allez pouvoir prendre un petit déjeuner
si ça passe encore des parties
allez on nous à l'autre sans le dire
enfin
faut qu'on voie les deux stages s'il
vous plaît ne soient régulières
[Musique]
à
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
il est minuit pile ce qui s'élance à ce
moment précis vont devoir courir en
moyenne près de 40 heures ils vont faire
l'équivalent de quatre marathons
d'affilée sans s'arrêter ou presque
ils ne vont que très peu dormir parfois
dans des conditions extrêmes le froid
l'humidité
tout est réuni pour en faire un calvaire
[Musique]
on les voit arriver là c'est c'est parti
nous sommes au poste du volcan les
favoris arrivent et repartent aussitôt
allez salut mais déjà un coup à chaque
fois qu'il est passé non voilà le
champion italien n'est pas là il a gagné
pas mal de courses extrêmes et puis il
faisait partie des favoris et là
apparemment il est pas là donc savait
difficile pour jouer pour lui le nom de
rejoint les premiers parce que donc la
course du grand raid se gagnent dans les
15 premiers quoi je veux dire donc il a
certainement une défaillance quoi
l'italien le champion italien
bah ouais bon que ces postes par charles
super continue un bravo l'arrivée au
volcan est un exploit physique
les coureurs ont parcouru seulement 30
kilomètres mais dans des conditions
impossibles pour le commun des mortels
pas de lumière un sol qui détruit les
cuisses ceux qui franchissent l'arrivée
après trois heures seulement sont des
athlètes hors du commun
à la vitesse où ces hommes courent dans
l'obscurité des accidents comme de
simples chutes peuvent prendre des
proportions parfois dramatiques frayer
un passage parmi les spectateurs qui
devrait être derrière les barrières ils
veulent tellement voir les coureurs de
près que sont très très près donc c'est
pas sa raison d'être
disciplinés mais presque
et l'italien fait son apparition c'est
lui qui inspire est de plus en plus
d'inquiétudes
son visage est déjà laminés par la
fatigue
c'est un désespoir de la course et là
apparemment il un petit problème il
serait prêt à abandonner
donc les médecins ça n'occupe pour faire
en sorte
il est reparti à la pause et est reparti
en italien qui a gagné la cause de
l'asthme en chine qui fait 125 préparant
s'améliore de champion et la concernant
l'un des grands favoris abandonne
finalement le tracé du volcan a déjà
fait sa première victime
tous ceux qui n'ont pas de badge s'il
vous plaît pas c'est derrière des
barrières merci mais c'est le passage en
cour à cacher
[Musique]
là une petite centaine de coureurs à
peine qui sont arrivés juste à l'heure
il va y avoir un gros rush donc il faut
que tout soit prêt vous connais pas mal
de stock de saint louis qui nous a fait
oui déjà découpé de soupçonner de
voisins
ça revient
on du nord un peu pris mes parents un
gros rush les ventes us en les
maintenant
le volcan est un site magnifique et
quand le jour va se lever ça va être
superbe le site du goal com c'est
vraiment beaucoup c'est pour ça que ça
fait six ans qu'on est là parce que
c'est vraiment une pause très chouette
très sympa les coureurs sont très très
chouette ils sont pas encore trop
fatigué donc on discute avec eux c'est
sympa et le lieu est magnifique
quand le soleil sera le 2 de les voir ça
va être superbe
[Musique]
bon
l'étape du volcan est l'une des plus
spectaculaires du grand raid
le piton de la fournaise est absolument
incroyable
la force qu'il dégage impressionne tous
ceux qui vont à sa rencontre
les spécialistes du monde entier
viennent régulièrement le voir c'est
l'un des volcans les plus actifs de la
planète
le décor autour du cratère nous projette
dans un autre univers courir ici c'est
une expérience unique
on ne reconnaît plus rien on découvre
une nouvelle forme terrestre les repères
volent en éclats
ici c'est l'humilité qui prend le pas
[Musique]
marc et si tu habites 16 points 3
56e qui passe déjà sept heures de course
pour certains coureurs et nous ne sommes
pas à la moitié du parcours
il est grand temps de reprendre quelques
forces la fatigue est bien présente sur
les visages
les corps ont été malmenés et le mental
on a déjà pris un coup la diagonale des
fous à frapper fort encore une fois 300
coureurs ont abandonné certains ne sont
même pas arrivés au poste ils sont tous
épuisés par un parcours chaotique mais
tu en as si rude épreuve le corps
je mélange emploi l'entraînement était
un peu limité l'accès
mes propres oreilles la nuit
la tête qu'est ce que vous faites qu'un
métier
nettoyage c'est vrai que un rythme à
deux nuits celtes un pur tension les
bonnes vous rêvez 12,8 chez vous piquez
le bout du doigt pour voir votre taux de
sucre marin non j'ai une petite piqûre
de rien de moins
google va la grosse piqûre n'en sait
pour barboteau sud
peut-être que vous manquez de sucre
ça va être plus le problème
d'entraînement sur
en montagne plutôt le problème c'est les
données blaikie qui ont des difficultés
à gérer leur vie d'avant il abandonnera
pas eh bah pas tout à fait il avait dit
qu'on verrait ça
comment vous sentez l'un genre projet
toujours
ouais je n'aurais pas l'énergie
là vous allez prenez la décision
d'abandonner l'un de ces précieux
lausanne n'a jamais donné une seule
course non non il vaut mieux si vous le
sentez pas ne faut pas les par contre
vous continuez à vous reposer puis on
voit 9h30 comment je peux vous rapatriez
vous avez quelqu'un pourquoi a contacté
la réparation était un compte actif
jusque je sache le
ou est ce qui peut vous retrouvez
souvent mon excitation à huy ouais bah
si quelqu'un chez vous glissant
on va forcément descendre sur la côte
maintenant pour vous amener à cilaos en
voiture ça va être plus difficile mais
pour redescendre sur la côte de
montmartre où quelqu'un et reposez-vous
maintenant après huit heures de course
deux nouveaux coureurs arrivés ceux là
ont pour objectif de finir le grand raid
pas question de figurer en bonne place
ils veulent juste finir ne pas
abandonner mais au poste de contrôle on
signale un dossard avis sont les
premières inquiétudes apparaissent vous
voyez quelqu'un d'ici 2 2
les bénévoles qui connaît un peu le
parcours donc donc là y est parti dix
minutes
[Musique]
donc en fait c'est des gens qui
l'attendait au texte or qui sont venus
me voir parce qu'ils connaissent et donc
donc a priori c'est un petit peu inquiet
parce que comme c'est quelqu'un qui a
l'habitude d'un marché qui est passée à
3h50 matin donc tu vois pas envie d'être
premier
non et puis ça pis y'a pas été pointé un
marabout donc non tu crois que répétait
le pointage mais non il y aurait neuf
heures de course les coureurs arrivent
toujours et ce n'est que la première
étape
les autres poursuivent leur grand raid
pas le temps de s'apitoyer sur ceux qui
sont déjà épuisés par la diagonale il
reste 120 kilomètres à parcourir
[Musique]
me
il
[Musique]
il n'ya mussard et pascal parny sont les
deux premiers arrivés au poste de cilaos
cela fait plus de huit heures qui
courent et ils ne vont même pas
s'arrêter il faut figure
d'extraterrestre les meilleurs athlètes
arrivent mais une bonne heure après les
deux peuples c'est là
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
perdu dans les montagnes si la hausse
est un poste clé du grand raid
nous sommes à 80 kilomètres de l'arrivée
on s'y arrête de longues minutes peut
être une heure ou plus pour les premiers
soins
les massages sont déterminants pour
continuer la compétition les cuisses
sont dur comme de la pierre mais elle
semble pouvoir se briser comme de l'art
d'oise à la moindre chute
diot bah oui mais au moins le tuyau vous
avez pas besoin de sortir la tête du sac
vraiment là je pense je vous assure pas
si le camel bag ça vous parle vous
réhydrater toutes les 15 minutes plutôt
que de sortir la bouteille d'eau parce
que là vous avez dû boire qui fait d'eux
un lézard
je demande aux éditions le bord quatre
cas ces bouteilles comme ça si on ne va
pas en afrique minimum faut boire mois
pour pas desperate et je pense vraiment
c'est dommage d'abandonner pour ça en
fait je pense vraiment qu'il y ait
douleur du range vous avez forcément bon
si vous êtes motivé et toujours moyen de
repartir
non en fait une santé pour manger mais
pas trop gentil d'avoir n'ont elles pas
loin d'un fera pas la moitié
en fait j'aime pas je sais mieux réalité
il va bien lui francophones sur leur vie
jamais leurs pieds non parce qu'après le
problème c'est comment ils vont
traverser de l'ama jusqu'ici non mais
sinon c'est un candidat rim
ils vont se laver les pieds ils vont se
laver les pieds et après on les soigne
faut quand même essayer d'être à leur
écoute parce que bon quand il arrive
comme ça ils sont déphasés la journée va
être longue
c'est wayne traitement woury bâ a
annoncé l'hôtel blanc il a dû taper et
s'est offert un pardon
c'est par contre
[Musique]
en fait il faudrait enlever le longue
l'épidermique way ma fraise ah non avec
le beast ou t'as pas une goule tadic
tengu m
[Applaudissements]
ouais c'est ici là ouais c'est un petit
tombe épidermique
ça fait comme un petit corps et vu la
position de l'orteil faux désépaissir la
zone en fait est là devant ici par ce
matin ça fait mal alors comme ça il ya
beaucoup de cailloux l'a pas dit que
bien chaussures qui a tourné qui c'est
la chaussure a tourné un moment prêt à
tourner puis le lepleux qui voit pied
venu taper dans un dans un caillou
combien puis voilà mince assange a en
france un petit peu longue et après dans
certaines configurations notamment à la
naissance
ça fait mal alors déjà j'ai fait un truc
j'ai changé de chaussures là où
ravitaillement passé dans l'essai au
mieux ce que j'ai essayé de faire c'est
de les porter au maximum du quatrième
pour essayer de faire en sorte que leur
pays soit plutôt comme sakho droit là il
faudra langue et il va tomber et on
l'espère on laisse comme femme c'est pas
mes centres au fur et à mesure des mois
sa marque ou c'est tout
bon courage à vous aussi
[Musique]
c'est la fin de la matinée les coureurs
arrivant flot continu parfois en couple
parfois seul est abattu
[Applaudissements]
jésus
c'est ça qui l'avait pas je sais que je
ne suis pas si tu vas mieux c'était
affaires de rechange après midi devait y
avoir un du point pris un point de
ravitaillement au dessus de kerveguen et
puis y avait rien c'est toujours plus ou
une heure et quart plus haut j'ai couru
1h15 sens bien sur la cgt
je vais deux fois il vient donner des
voitures sur le circuit
c'est un souci de plus pour eric le
responsable des bénévoles salle est ce
qu'on appelle les récalcitrants ceux qui
ne respectent pas l'organisation mise en
place
savage avait lâché non malheureusement
salut ça va ben c'est vrai que tu vas tu
as mal gré je dirais l'organisation mise
en place comme on voit là on trouve
toujours des gens qui te dirai qui vient
gêner en quelque sorte la veine de sio
je ne sais pas le plan de circulation
qui a été mise en place par le le
responsable ici je pense qu'on aurait dû
interdire la circulation dans cette
petit truc grand raid c'est qui est
surprenant qu'un os x les concurrents au
bout d'un certain nombre de kilomètres
quand on les encourage par leur prénom
ils sont étonnés tiens on me connaît
alors que tout compte fait non on ne
fait que lire sur leurs dossards leur
prénom et ça ça les surprend
bravo marque allez jean paul super
le cirque de cilaos est exceptionnel au
regard du dessin de ces montagnes et de
sa végétation
si les coureurs en profite pleinement
pendant la course et à condition de ne
pas être blessé
c'est dans les airs que le spectacle
prend toute sa dimension
ici les hélicoptères tournent dans un
ballet incessant pour apporter des
secours faire un point sur la course ou
envoyer des images du grand raid aux
nombreuses chaînes de télévision
[Musique]
des coureurs font une pause au sommet
d'une crête de plusieurs centaines de
mètres de hauteur
c'est un moment exceptionnel pour ses
hommes détruit par la dureté du parcours
cela ne savent pas combien les montées
et les descentes vont encore se succéder
[Musique]
plus bas pascal pas renié et didier
mussard ne s'attarde pas sur le décor
ils sont toujours en tête plus que
jamais et cela fait dix-sept heures
qu'ils courent sans jamais prendre de
pause c'est à peine croyable
vous aviez finir ensemble c'est décidé
c'est arte comme ça didier mussard
arrive premier au poste de deux bras il
a avalé 121 km ha sont prenants 17h02 de
course mais c'est l'assuré parce que
pass pascal est la piscine attendant -
ben omonia décidé c'est fini avec mr va
gagner
nice n'est que vers son siège dans la
redoutable ses cuisses le fond
horriblement souffrir et il ne peut pas
s'arrêter
le second pascal parny est à ses côtés
en deuxième position et c'est par nicky
a l'air plus frais les deux hommes sont
côte à côte dans un duel exceptionnel
ils ne se lâchent plus depuis le poste
du volcan toujours aucune pause pour les
deux frères ennemis du grand raid
ils ont pourtant une heure d'avancé sur
le troisième
mais la victoire se joue entre deux
maintenant
[Applaudissements]
lorsque l'on ne dispose pas d'un
hélicoptère c'est en 4/4 qu'il faut se
déplacer pour accéder à deux bras le
tracé du grand raid passe par des
chemins complètement défoncée et ici
mieux vaut avoir des suspensions solide
pour dévaler les routes rempli de roches
et de cours d'eau
l'autre moyen de parvenir au poste de
deux bras 7 à pied à condition d'avoir
les genoux aussi solide que les 4,4 avec
la fatigue on peut facilement se casser
une cheville il n'ya plus que 25 km
avant l'arrivée mais les coureurs ont
tout donné pour se rendre jusqu'ici
certains l'ont même dangereusement
dépasser leurs limites
les médecins ont donc un rôle crucial à
cette étape a eu de raisonner les
coureurs pour éviter l'accident parfois
dramatiques
c'est pas bien méchant ça m'échappe et
donner un petit peu de dafalgan puis ça
repart
oui oui d'accord ça marque
on a tenu le coup jusqu'à depuis le
temps qu en fait
jusqu'à 10 de leur jeu les 105 entier
ouais
et jenny leveurs pour faire remplacer
on
deux fois j'ai vu ni connu
hawaii m 2
sur scène vous arrivez à manger c'est
bon en fait il est vrai que j'avais
arrêté de marcher rapidement j refroidi
nous avait en même temps les courbatures
plus le reste je pouvais plus poser un
pied parce que là j'ai laissé tomber
j'ai couru sur des on va on va frapper
de l'annoncé de fillon s'est déjà bien
finir il ya des pépins qu'on maîtrise
pas
l'organisme est l'un est comme ça il ya
des choses qui arrivent qu'on maîtrise
pas déjà des trêves d'avoir fait ce que
vous avez fait avec ça c'est déjà à faut
donc on va continuer sa prochaine va
continuer non moi la redoute c'est
presqu'à côté là
d'accord c'est bon
on va se taper après vous revenez me
voir je me tonita fan gang pour pouvoir
continuer et ok moi je suis pressé de
rentrer chez moi je les plus pressés de
le donc c'est pour ça qu'il faut que
vous êtes combien la l'ajustant et 320
je crois un peu comme ça les derniers
kilomètres a dévalé sont les pires les
jambes ne répondent plus comme un saint
philippe au départ elle semble se
dérober sous le poids de la fatigue et
la dure qu'elle est pierre
voilà
j'ai été très bons en maths où je fais
les trois premiers en demi finale sans
problème est là donc ça alors je vous
dirai ça au fur et à mesure qu'on est là
c'est plus possible et sa chance qui a
racheté après la descente est d'autant
plus douloureuse
j'ai dit on va être fait dans un four
décembre
tp 10 heures de trouver quelque chose
c'est on a fait avec des tirs et je
crois que c'est avant tout une histoire
de plaisir non là bon j'ai dit voilà je
dirais pioche plâtre été assez
douloureux donc ses préférés pas rater
parce que je force écrit dessus
et puis les bains dans deux ans
[Musique]
et
arrêter ici la déception est terrible
pour certains le sentiment d'impuissance
est écrasant impossible de continuer
plus rien ne répond les corps sont
désarticulés et l' envie d'aller au bout
c'est effacés on n'écoute même plus ce
qui se dit l'aventuré est belle et bien
terminée
[Musique]
m
la course continue
[Musique]
les corps sont épuisés l'assiduité dans
les épreuves du parcours n'est plus
vraiment la même
les coureurs souffre terriblement pour
venir à bout des tout derniers
kilomètres
les jambes sont les premiers à se
dérober elles sont chancelante devenue
fragile
on y arrive tout simplement plus
[Musique]
le grand raid après 20 heures de marche
est devenue un enfer pas des souffrances
[Musique]
désormais nous sommes à quelques
kilomètres de l'arrivée les fous du
grand raid traverseront ce parcours avec
40 heures de course dans les jambes
plus d'un millier de coureurs
n'arriveront jamais à ce stade
accident abandon temps de passage trop
faible
et pourtant la ville de saint denis se
dessine au loin
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
18h33 de course pascal parny le
réunionnais arrive seul au poste de dos
d'âne
didier mussard qui a fait toute la
course avec lui n'est plus à ses côtés
c'est jasmin la responsable du poste qui
tente d' accueillir le mieux possible le
réunionnais on veut quelque chose à
ravitailler
il passe un peu de patrie nana à tommy
faire maintenant tout ça tout de suite
prévoit de les pattes pour le monsieur
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
[Rires]
allez bon courage
paris c'est paris
bon sang vient de nouveau derrière
venaient au passage dix minutes plus
tard didier mussard apparaît dans la
nuit il est second après avoir fait
toute la course en tête
il vient de parcourir 128 km d'une
centrale
il sait qu'il faudrait un miracle pour
revenir sur pascal parny le numéro 1 a
laissé par ici venez vous ravitailler
non il vaut rien mais l'assistance de la
famille donc ça va on va le voir oui
alors ça va c'est votre coureur c'est le
seul chef de poste
bonsoir alors s'il a besoin de moi que
ce soit ou de me demander de lui il a
besoin de l'eau et tout ça ça va il a
refait un peu non il est pas très loin
du premier donc ne vous en faites pas
ces séries c'est le sérieux nécessaire
mais ça me dit monsieur monsieur ça ça
va ça passe c'est le chef de poste mais
je prends un peu de vos nouvelles ça va
oui oui mais ça va hein ça va aller mal
soit besoin quoi que ce soit si elle a
besoin de quoi que ce soit besoin de
l'eau non
à l'éperon c'est bien tu sais très bien
manger mais sinon la très minimale sont
là les deux premiers coureurs vont finir
en moins de 24 heures l'ensemble du
parcours
mais ils restent tous les autres les
plus vaillants mettront une trentaine
d'heures pour arriver au stade de
saint-denis
le dernier sera comptabilisée à 64
heures et huit minutes
près d'un millier d'hommes et de femmes
ne verront jamais la ligne d'arrivée
comme chaque année le grand raid est
beaucoup trop difficile non pas à gagner
mais a terminé tout simplement les
quatre marathons consécutifs que
représente la diagonale des fous sont
une vraie folie accomplir même si ces
hommes et ces femmes se sont entraînés
durant toute une année pour venir ici
alors avant de fouler le sol de
l'arrivée on fait une pause on ouvre les
yeux et on contemple une dernière fois
la splendeur de lille
il
[Musique]
oh là là les produits se trouvaient les
occuper mais là c'est une urgence
à ce moment précis le directeur de la
course est l'objet de toutes les
sollicitations la santé d'un des
coureurs est alarmante
il n'a pas fini la course et se fait
soigner directement dans le stade
il s'est fait rapatrier par le samu les
chutes le manque de préparation les
malaise soudain beaucoup de choses sur
le grand raid peuvent s'avérer fatal
lors de la course
les médecins sont omniprésents sur le
parcours surtout vers la fin quand des
hommes et des femmes sont exténués par
la course et qu'ils avancent comme des
pantins
ils ne se rendent plus compte à ce
moment-là du danger qu'ils encourent
mais la santé des athlètes n'est pas le
seul motif d'inquiétude
on a un souci sur une personne qui s'est
perdu donc normalement ça devrait se
régler que veut dire donc j'ai vu la
responsable du poste est apparemment
donc apparue vraiment
elle s'est pas perdue parce que le
balisage est correct et fait demi-tour
en fin de compte surgères c'est pourquoi
non en fonction les savoirs c'est qu'on
a des collègues sur le parcours ont été
déroutés à dire ils n'ont pas pu
continuer parce que les premiers
arrivaient du mouret dès qu'il ya de la
barrière horaire
voilà ce qu'on observe à petit ses
bâtisseurs parce qu'elle est illusion le
ticket pour mon jeu parce qu'ils sont là
non mais on verra ce soir vers joueurs
sont à leur sens aller chose que j'aurai
de bonnes et sa non de vente parce que
ça nous regarde et mangeait tout à fait
c'est les collègues en fait on les nomme
est trop proche cdf en dessous là
d'ailleurs si apathiques et non la
tension monte chaque instant un peu plus
pour les organisateurs les tout petits
problèmes prennent des proportions de la
douze ans plus importante
on s'explique on s'impose mais on sait
que tous les problèmes s'effaceront dès
que l'élu de la diagonale fera son
apparition
le peuple attend maintenant son idole
celui qui a traversé l'une des plus
belles villes au monde celui qui a su
défier cette végétation hostile pour
terminer le premier est l'homme qui va
arriver à réaliser un véritable exploit
21h40 à courir des falaises des cours
d'eau des ravins des températures
variant de 30 degrés le jour à 5 degrés
la nuit
la performance est au delà de ce que
l'on peut imaginer
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
et la délivrance fini par arriver il
s'appelle pascal parny le grand raid
offre à la foule un nouveau prodige la
réunion le célébrera pendant toute une
année
on sait trop bien ici sur cette île ce
que cet homme a dû fournir qu'un effort
pour arriver en tête devant plus de 2000
sportifs de haut niveau
c'est un sacre qui attend le coureur
pascal parny un nom gravé dans la
légende celle qu'on appelle à juste
titre la diagonale des fous
[Musique]